la parole est maintenant monsieur marc
fesneau du groupe mouvement démocrate et
apparentés de l'assemblée nationale vous
avez la parole monsieur finaux pour 10
minutes maximum
monsieur le président du congrès
monsieur le président du sénat monsieur
le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires chers
collègues
c'est un jour solennel que celui où le
président de la république convoquant le
congrès à versailles s'adresse à
l'ensemble des parlementaires et à
travers eux au peuple français
la gravité du lieu et du moment doit
nous inciter à prendre la mesure de ce
qui nous réunit
le président de la république a choisi
de s'exprimer devant l'ensemble des
hommes et des femmes que les français
par l'exercice de leurs droits de
citoyens ont voulu investir des pouvoirs
qui sont ceux de la nation tout entière
dans le seul but de répondre aux défis
qui se posent à notre pays il a souhaité
présenter devant le parlement les
grandes lignes de son action et définir
le sens et le cap qu'il souhaite donner
la solennité de l'instant nous impose
donc à tous députés et sénateurs un
devoir de responsabilité responsabilité
du rôle qu'il est désormais le nôtre
face au français qui attendent de leurs
représentants et de ceux qui les
gouvernent qu'il réponde de manière
déterminée et efficace aux problèmes de
notre temps et nous savons combien ils
sont nombreux et combien ils sont lourds
dans la situation n'a cessé de se
dégrader au cours des dernières
décennies
nourrissant la colère d'une grande part
de notre peuple qui est las d'attendre
des résultats responsabilité surtout
quand on compte que nous aurons
collectivement à ronde à rendre de notre
action à la fin de notre mandat
ne doutons pas que les français sauront
nous rappeler nos deux à nos devoirs et
à nos engagements et à être aussi
implacable avec nous si nous devions
faillir qu'ils auront été enthousiaste a
souhaité un profond changement pour le
pays les campagnes qui s'achève ont
laissé un goût amer à tous ceux qui
chérissent l'action politique
elles ont vu pour la campagne
présidentielle tout d'abord accédé au
deuxième tour et pour le deuxième fois
une candidate issue des extrêmes et pour
la campagne des législatives ensuite les
citoyens se détourner largement d'un
scrutin pourtant si cruciale disons le
simplement la reconquête des coeurs et
de l'attention des français ne se fera
que par l'otan
de résultat net et durable qui
garantiront l'avenir de notre pays et
par le rétablissement de la confiance
entre les représentants du peuple que
nous sommes et les citoyens cette
responsabilité historique le groupe
modem depuis longtemps investi sur ce
sujet en temps l'assumer pleinement au
sein de la majorité que vous conduisez
monsieur le premier ministre est aux
côtés du président de la république la
majorité que nous formons veut être au
service des français et nous nous
reconnaissons parfaitement dans le cas
proposé par le chef de l'état depuis le
début de son mandat et exprimer ce jour
devant le congrès je le dis et je là si
mon nom de mon groupe
aujourd'hui notre responsabilité de
parlementaires et de permettre au
gouvernement de mettre en oeuvre le plus
tôt possible
les propositions du candidat emmanuel
macron que les français ont placé en
tête du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle avant de les lire par la
suite et a donc pour nous simplement la
volonté d'agir et d'agir vite pour que
les français qui par deux fois en
conscience et en toute liberté
on fait les choix de réforme que la
majorité portent puisse voir se réaliser
les changements qu'ils attendent depuis
si longtemps la ligne sur laquelle nous
nous engageons est une ligne de crête
car jamais dans notre histoire récente
sans doute la défiance n'a été aussi
grande vis-à-vis du monde politique
nous sommes tous les porte voix du
peuple français nous devons nous vous
souvenir que si nous en avons tous nous
avons tous une terre d'élection nous à
son monsieur non individuellement une
part de la souveraineté de tout un
peuple de ses espoirs que nous soyons de
la majorité comme de l'opposition
depuis longtemps nous avons identifié ce
mal qui ronge notre démocratie qui
détache peu à peu les citoyens de leurs
élus l'action résolue des élus du
mouvement démocrate en faveur d'un
rapprochement des citoyens avec leur
institution témoigne de notre volonté de
rendre notre démocratie plus
représentatives et plus ouverte
ainsi la loi pour la confiance dans
notre vie démocratique va dans le sens
d'un renforcement de nos institutions
d'une amélioration de l'efficacité de
notre fonctionnement et d'une meilleure
réponse aux exigences du temps le non
cumul des mandats y compris dans la
durée l'impératif d'exemplarité des élus
l'encadrement renforcé de nos activités
tout cela doit permettre de ramener la
confiance chez nos concitoyens
il s'agit de la condition même de la
légitimité de la parole et de l'action
politique sans quoi aucune réforme
durable ne sera possible
l'abstention toujours plus forte à
chaque élection rend d'autant plus
nécessaire une telle réforme et les
autres réformes institutionnelles
annoncées aujourd'hui par le président
de la république vont qui est garante de
nos institutions vont y concourir ainsi
la constitution d'une juste
représentation de toutes les forces
politiques dans nos assemblées de la
proportionnelle pour garantir aux
français leur plus juste et plus
équitable représentation est posée c'est
une question centrale pour notre vie et
pour notre respiration démocratique
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires vous le
savez notre bloc ne se retrouvent ne se
réunit jamais mieux qu autour d'idéaux
autour d'un grand dessein et d'une
vision les français connaissent toute la
profondeur des temps et de l'histoire
ils savent la portée de notre message
universel qui depuis toujours fait de
lui un peuple soucieux des autres quand
ses représentants ne sont pas à la
hauteur de cette histoire c'est toute la
france qui se perd et son message qui
s'affaiblit
quant au contraire ils le sont et en
premier lieu le chef de l'état l'unité
le rayonnement redeviennent possible
le président de la république s'inscrit
pleinement et de plain pied dans cette
volonté de restaurer dans notre pays
dans ce qu'il a de si spécifique dans
son fonctionnement et en même temps de 6
universelle en deux mois à peine on
perçoit la réaffirmation des positions
traditionnelles de la france que ce soit
dernièrement au g7 sur les enjeux
économiques mon dieu ou concernant
l'enjeu capital du monde du climat ou
bien encore sur celui de la sécurité la
voix de la france est devenue plus
lisible en europe aussi nous nous
réjouissons de voir la france renoué
avec l'idéal et le projet originel
européens y compris dans le lien
indéfectible que nous avons avec
l'allemagne le président de la
république a su nway ce dialogue nouveau
été français avec la france et avec nos
partenaires internationaux
tout reste à faire bien entendu mais
nous le sentons partout dans nos
territoires plus que jamais la france en
prête à bouger a changé attentes et elle
attend désormais que nous soyons au
rendez-vous de l'espérance qui s'est
levé ce printemps elle attend que par
nos actes notre capacité de dialogue et
notre écoute nous réformions est là
quand elle espère peut-être surtout de
retrouver la confiance en ceux qui la
gouvernent
et retrouver la confiance en elle même
cet élan chers collègues il nous faut le
soutenir hardiment avec la lucilie avec
lucidité avec exigence et avec toute la
force du profond renouvellement qui
s'est opéré ces derniers mois et cette
volonté que beaucoup d'entre nous
incarne sur ses bancs jeu le premier
ministre ce n'est pas se payer de mots
que de considérer votre action comme
porteuse porteuse d'une nouvelle
ambition pour la france
la voix de la france est attendu écouter
et nous nous réjouissons qu'elle le soit
de l'acca soit celle de la tolérance du
dialogue de l'ouverture de l'idéal de
liberté de ces valeurs européennes et
humaniste qui nous sont chères votre
action pourra s'appuyer sur les
parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle et du groupe au nom
duquel je m'exprime aujourd'hui l'esprit
de conquête des mots mêmes du président
de la république parle à l'imaginaire de
notre pays et fondent notre destin
commun c'est un tel souffle dans notre
pays a besoin
l'élection d' emmanuel macron la
constitution d'une majorité claire
autour de vous monsieur le premier
ministre suscite espoirs et attentes
à nous d'être désormais au rendez vous
fixé avec le peuple français et que le
président de la république est venu
exprimer et rappeler cet après midi à
notre congrès celui de nous confronter
au réel pour mieux pouvoir servi notre
idéal celui d'institutions moderniser
lisible et qui permette le débat et la
vie démocratique
celui enfin d'un pays fier de lui et sûr
de lui même et qui parle au reste du
monde
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]